what's going on guys Greg al be here
with awesome iphone camera quality so i
just got done at the gym LA fitness LA
fitness and a lot of you guys having a
lot of comments lately a lot of you guys
are saying you notice how much would
have been losing and i don't really
notice it because i see myself everyday
but when you guys say it makes me feel
good so I appreciate that a lot thank
you and I have been putting in the
effort past couple months especially so
thank you very much um I was thinking
about a lot of things in the gym today
you know like I didn't want to work out
but I was feeling very frustrated as
feeling a lot of anxiety I was feeling
worried and because I was feeling those
things I was like you know I man just
work out and help calm you down so I
feel a little more calm and that there
are things that I just kind of wanted to
talk about really crap it's about all
this YouTube [ __ ] so much [ __ ] on
YouTube man and behind the scenes the
real rejects yeah a lot of the changes
since like September that have been
occurring with the algorithm the
restricted mode and if you guys have
heard about YouTube losing 750 million
dollars in ads in product placement or
whatever the [ __ ] I don't know if you
guys follow like drama alert or
PewDiePie or Philip DeFranco they've
been they've talked about this in quite
a few videos and yeah it's greatly
affected the channel yes you know some
views have gone down but I was still you
know still able to like make a living
thanks see you guys so all you guys have
supported the channel have contributed
your time to watching the videos helping
get us views I've been fortunate enough
to have made a living off of youtube the
past couple years and when I say make a
living I mean make a living I haven't
you know it's so weird when you're like
talking to a camera than people pull it
next to I haven't achieved you know
wealth I am not even close to middle
class but I was able to replace my job
and that's what I cared most about was
just I didn't want to work a regular job
I thought I'd be cool to be able to
work from home and commit those hours of
work to just you know filming and
editing and allowed me to have the time
to work on side project side projects
that probably don't go up to youtube
right away like I've been writing
scripts again lately and focusing on
developing other skills and talents and
venturing off into different parts
outside of YouTube so I going after my
real big dreams but why I'm here is
because it i'm not exactly sure why I'm
here I just felt like talking about it
YouTube has been going down the [ __ ]
lately to give you guys an idea back in
september-october whenever the algorithm
changed happened and like I said I've
been making a living haven't been rich
or anything making a living and then my
income shot down by about forty to fifty
percent and this was common I talked to
so many other youtubers not going to
mention any names because they haven't
mentioned in their videos and stuff but
I know plenty of other people who do
YouTube and a lot of them were talking
about how not only did the reviews dip
their income dipped and then even the
videos and this has happened with our
channel to even the videos that have
been getting a lot of views have not
been paying anywhere near as much as
they used to and a lot of us make our
living off what we pay our rent we pay
our bills repair health insurance to pay
everything off of youtube so when that
started happening it was scary we
thought youtube would fix it now with
the YouTube losing 750 million dollars i
mean sorry for for youtube at the guys
at the top that's a lot of money to lose
it's been affecting a lot of people i
know as well including me see back from
the back in september-october income
shot down bout bout like forty to fifty
percent now it's shut down to about
seventy to eighty percent this past few
weeks I would be better off this how'd
it but now haunts I'd be better off as
mental wise I would suck but financial
wise I would be making more money at the
job I had prior to you too
the way how things have been going and
it's it's scary it's I'm not giving up
this ain't like I'm quitting video but
it has been rough lately I mean I'm sure
you guys have noticed that if you guys
like do the math just look at our
channel around september-october view
started dipping a lot some people like
to be smart asses on YouTube you'd be
like all your videos are low I've talked
to other people people who have whose
channels are still growing in subscriber
count who say that like gather they're
getting a much smaller fraction of video
views than the amount they have like
their average video view count has shot
down a lot like to give you an example
are like right when the algorithm change
happened our average video view count
was around 50 to 60 k views per video
and now it's shot down to about 10 to 20
case per video right when the algorithm
happened and now with this ad thing like
you guys got to understand like the way
how YouTube works is you put up a video
YouTube takes forty five percent of what
you've already of what the video earned
they already take forty five percent and
if you're in a lot of youtubers like
myself we're partnered with a
multi-channel network and they usually
take between a ten to twenty percent cut
depending on the negotiation you guys
struck up so you're usually videos will
get views and then you'll usually only
take home about somewhere between thirty
to forty percent of that actual income
which is fine you know the youtubes of
the biggest media site on the world and
you know like they let you put up videos
for free doesn't cost money to put up
videos so if they're going to take a big
pay cut okay I could settle with that
but with the money dipping so much it
has been getting me kind of scared it
has been getting me kind of worried in a
little stress and a little short with
some people on Twitter and stuff and um
so I just wanted to to let you guys know
that you know there's a lot of people
experiencing drama there's a lot of
people experiencing like some serious
behind-the-scenes youtube drama some
people are cooking really considering
quitting and stopping youtube and just
getting a regular job some people are
looking for
platforms other people are looking for a
variety of different ways to pull in
money this year is was my year where I'm
going to where I wanted to focus on my
bigger aspirations like I wrote a pilot
and a couple days ago I submitted it it
takes a while for a pilot to go through
development it's getting great feedback
right now can't tell you any guys you
guys any details about where i sent it
to or who might be going through but
it's getting really good feedback right
now but i can't depend on a pilot
getting picked up because that's that's
that's like weeks of progress of that
happening if I'm fortunate enough for
the pilot to get picked up and then we
got this other they got another thing in
the works with another youtube channel
actually that's pretty exciting so we're
not giving up I'm not giving up I have
there's other things I'm working on as
well I just wanted to let you guys know
that with the dip with the view dip the
income did subscribers not gathering as
much the annoyance of the algorithm and
I've talked to a lot of youtubers bigger
than myself who say that right when they
upload they lose a bunch of subscribers
and that happens almost every single
time I hope I don't lose subscribers
until i upload a video and then suddenly
a bunch of accounts clothes I've gotten
a lot of messages to of people telling
me that YouTube keeps unsubscribing them
and I just wanted to let you guys know
that yeah YouTube is affecting my life
as well but I'm here to stay and I ain't
gonna go down quitting or what's the
word I'm not going down hopefully
YouTube will turn itself around
hopefully things will get back to normal
and we could all work at a steady calm
relaxed pace and everyone can go back to
just giving you the videos they look
because the thing is it can be difficult
than a little challenging sometimes to
just sit in front of a camera and you
know just do it for the love of it when
it's the when the the benefits of it are
just not as present anymore I have
nothing to complain about I'm still
alive I still of still was able to make
rent this month
so I'm okay for at least another month
we'll just see how June's looking but
other than that I still love all you
guys for all you people who still watch
the videos and for anyone who's new to
the channel YouTube is going through
some hell right now but I'm one of the
people along with many others who are
saying we're still going to stick around
in hopes that things will turn around
and we won't give up will stay until
YouTube decides to shut down permanently
goodbye I love you and some people still
through well Tyrone Magnus a 1 million
subs today [ __ ] yeah good for you dude